the peace deal came as a surprise to
many president salva kiir and rebel
leader react mushara signed an agreement
a short time after their first
face-to-face meeting details are to be
worked out in the coming days the
Ethiopian president was instrumental in
the success of the talks by signing this
agreement boss President Salva Kiir
Madrid and dr. react mature have
underscored that there is no military
solution to the crisis and South Sudan
and sustainable solution can be achieved
only through inclusive political process
according to the agreement all fighting
will cease within 24 hours a
transitional government will be formed
followed by fresh elections there have
been mass atrocities in the country
since the conflict broke out tens of
thousands of civilians have fallen
victim women children the elderly
observers say that peace will be
difficult to sustain but there is hope
nobody will again opened fire on another
passer I'm sending the signal that this
one whipped must be ended peacefully
international relief organizations hope
that the deal will open the way for
humanitarian assistance for some 1
million civilians the test now is
whether both sides will uphold their end
of the Accord